the lifeblood of this protest is the
funding behind it organizers have raised
more than 10 million dollars first on
crowdfunding platform gofundme then over
give send go but it's been one obstacle
after another for protesters to actually
get the money on monday sweeping changes
targeting banks and crowdfunding
platforms were announced under the
emergencies act these changes cover all
forms of transactions
including digital assets
such as
currencies what the world has witnessed
here
is the power of government
to manipulate
the flows of people's hard-earned
dollars all of this driving the movement
to bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
and even digital assets like nfts
anti-money laundering experts tell
global news these fall into a gray area
crypto experts say cracking down on
bitcoin itself is complicated but
authorities have an opportunity to act
when that crypto is turned into cash
gift cards or prepaid cards this
forensic accountant is waiting to find
out more about what specifically is
covered under the emergencies act once
it makes its way through parliament this
is a fascinating shift uh and it
provides lots of powers in financial
institutions that you know
i'm not sure is is uh
not sure is a great thing for the long
term alex tapscott's specialty is
blockchain the technology that underpins
bitcoin he warns of unintended
consequences with the spotlight on
bitcoin and other digital assets let's
not throw the baby out with the bath
water let's take a cautious and
deliberate approach to regulating any
new technology that comes along the
concern among technologists is that
temporary new rules put in place during
an emergency could eventually be adopted
and hinder economic growth and
innovation in fintech long after this
convoy is cleared out
donna